.
>> Rachel: ROBBY, THANKS FOR
JOINING ME TONIGHT.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Rachel: DEMOCRATS THINK IT'S
TIME FOR NANCY PELOSI TO BE
REWARDED FOR HER HARD WORK.
SO MUCH SO THAT THEY HAVE
EARMARKED $200 MILLION JUST FOR
HER FAVORITE SAN FRANCISCO PARK.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS TRIED TO BLOCK
THE PROPOSAL SAYING THE MONEY
COULD BE BETTER USED LITERALLY
ANYWHERE ELSE DEMOCRATS DIDN'T
CARE.
THEY THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA TO
USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO UPGRADE
THE PREVIDEO PARK IN PELOSI'S
DISTRICT BECAUSE THEE DESERVES
IT.
>> IF IT WEREN'T FOR HER WORKING
24/7 AND SHE DOES IT TO KEEP
THIS PLACE GOING WE WOULDN'T BE
GOING.
SHE DOES MORE FOR AMERICA THAN
ANY OTHER MEMBER I WOULD SUBMIT
IN THIS CONGRESS TIMES 10.
SO I SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
>> JOINING ME NOW TO REACT FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TAMMY BRUCE.
TAMMY, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I SHOP AT
WALMART.
I'M KIND OF A -- YOU KNOW, I
LIKE TO SAVE MY PENNIES,
200 MILLION FOR A PARK, NOT EVEN
A NEW PARK.
IT'S TO JUST TO RENOVATE THE
PARK.
WHAT THE HECK?
>> YEAH.
LOOK, AND IT'S FUNNY TO LISTEN
TO COHEN SAYING OH SHE DESERVES
IT BECAUSE OF ALL THE WORK SHE
DOES AND EVERYBODY HAS BEEN OUT.
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN DOING THEIR
ZOOMING.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN IN THERE.
IT'S FUNNY.
LOOK, IT'S NOW LIKE MONOPOLY
MONEY.
NOTHING TO THEM LIKE MR. MONEY
BAGS THROWING AROUND THE CASH.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE
KNOW DEALING WITH THIS PRESIDIO
HIGH END REAL ESTATE, IT'S
HOTELS, FANCY CONDOS, FANCY
ELITE HOMES.
A GOLF COURSE.
RIGHT?
IT'S A GREAT PLACE TO VISIT.
NO WONDER SHE LOVES IT SO MUCH.
>> Rachel: I HAVE BEEN THERE.
IT'S PRETTY.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS WHAT THIS ICE
CREAM-EATING AND MARTINI
DRINKING BUBBLE THINKS ABOUT
THEMSELVES THAT WE WORK FOR
THEM.
REMEMBER, THAT'S OUR MONEY SHE
IS SPENDING.
PART OF WHAT THE REPUBLICANS
SUGGESTED WHAT ABOUT MONEY FOR
GOLD STAR FAMILIES FOR VETERANS
AND THEIR EDUCATION?
I WOULD ADD WHAT ABOUT FUNDING
THE POLICE?
WHAT ABOUT INSTEAD OF PUTTING
200 MILLION IN THAT ELITE AREA
WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF SAN
FRANCISCO THAT HAS BECOME A
DUMPSTER FIRE?
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
STATEMENT ABOUT THEIR ELITISM
AND WHAT THEY THINK OF US, WHICH
IS NOTHING.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY VIEW EACH
OTHER AS, YOU KNOW, MASTERS OF
THE UNIVERSE WHICH, OF COURSE,
THAT'S NOT QUITE WHAT THEY ARE
TO SAY THE LEAST.
>> Rachel: YEAH, ALSO APPEARS TO
BE A PAY BACK BECAUSE THE PRES
IDIO TRUST.
I DON'T KNOW ANY PARK THAT I
VISIT THAT HAS ITS OWN TRUST BUT
THIS PARK DOES.
THE PRE SEDIO GAVE NANCY PELOSI
$19 MILLION IN DONATIONS OVER
THE LAST YEAR.
$1 MILLION IN JUNE.
WOW, THEY ARE USING THAT MONEY
TO PAY OFF THEIR DONORS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SO THERE YOU HAVE GOT -- THAT OF
COURSE, IS JUST A LITTLE CASH IN
HER HAND, RIGHT?
THIS IS ABOUT 200 MILLION.
TALK ABOUT A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT.
20 MILLION BUCKS TO NANCY
PELOSI, YOU KNOW, 10 TIMES IS
WHAT YOU WILL GET BACK OF OUR
MONEY, THIS IS IN THE NORMAL
BUSINESS WORLD, THAT WOULD BE
GRIFFITH.
IT WOULD BE EMBEZZLINGMENT.
STHL WHAT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
IS THE NATURE OF WHAT THEY GET
AWAY WITH SO OFTEN, RACHEL.
THEN WE WONDER WHY THEY TREAT
US -- WE THEY BEHAVE LIKE
CRIMINALS AND TREAT US LIKE WE
ARE LITTLE IRRITANT CHIHUAHUAS
BITING AT THEIR ANKLES.
THEY HAVE GOT TO GATE WAKE-UP
CALL NEXT YEAR TO SAY THE LEAST.
ALL OF THIS HAS TO CHANGE.
>> TUCKED INTO $3.5 TRILLION
BILL.
I GUESS YOU KNOW HUNDRED MILLION
SEEMS LIKE CHUMP CHANGE.
WE SHOULD ALL BE ABLE TO GO TO
THE PARK AND GET SOME OF HER
FANCY ICE CREAM FOR FREE IF WE
GO.
>> YEAH.
ICE CREAM FOR EVERYONE.
THE BIGGEST FREEZER OF ICE
CREENEL ON GOD'S GREEN EARTH IN
EVERY CITY OF THE COUNTRY.
BUT, NO, THAT WON'T HAPPEN
EITHER BECAUSE THEY ARE MEAN.
>> Rachel: THEY ARE MEAN.
TAMMY, YOU ARE NOT MEAN.
I LOVE YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING M